I don't think I ever have a particular
set of points as to a character that I
want to play there's no hard and fast
rules it's will have to be something
that hopefully sparks my interest that I
feel is outside of the kind of gender
norms that we've seen portrayed in our
entertainment as something that teaches
us about what it is to be human if I can
see a spark of authentic humanity in the
character then that makes me really want
to play it
I find the audition process incredibly
difficult and intimidating and it wasn't
always something I had a huge amount of
practice that either I think as time has
gone by really just investing in the
work and finding something that sparks
your interest I remember that's what my
art teacher taught me was make it
personal and then if you've got that to
hang on to then you can stop worrying
about how you can't stop blushing and
you want to go to the toilet all the
time a friend told me in 2011 that there
was something written about me on the
Internet
being in an HBO show and so I looked it
up I'd never done anything like that
before
and I saw all of these incredible fan
forums featuring my name I googled the
character I thought you should just read
the books first that is my training but
I couldn't wait I had to know what the
character was
and that really blew my mind the idea
that there might be this portrayal of a
woman in mainstream entertainment he was
entirely unconventional who was
physically very strong there wasn't the
most interesting thing about them was
the interesting thing about her is that
that is coupled with a extreme
sensitivity vulnerability and while she
was achieving these huge and impressive
and deeply skilled physical feats that
she was slowly developing as a person as
a woman and as a human like a sort of
rite of passage that she goes through
and also it
examine what it is to be unconventional
particularly as a woman within society
what interested me the most which George
on our Martin did so brilliantly and
David and Dan have done wonderfully is
that it was about overcoming the
obstacle it wasn't just about being
mocked for being outside of society it
was about overcoming that obstacle and
changing attitudes and that made me want
to play the part so badly I then read
all of Brian's story I read as much of
the books I could I think I read up to
the end of book three
I read voraciously I started physically
training this is all before the audition
how could I do anything all of them that
take that amazing opportunity seriously
the second audition actually lasted
maybe five minutes and I thought okay so
I've got that or that just went so so
badly so so badly I found out I got the
job and then the real work began and I
started training with the brilliant Cece
Smith who's a coaching directing
stuntman legend and he taught me how to
fight how to sword fight we worked on
the way I walked the way I held my body
and he really pushed me so I was able to
achieve things I never thought I could
like fighting a man that six foot seven
and weighs 20 T stone sorry Rory
preparation involved many many different
things it can involve as it has done
most prominently on Game of Thrones a
lot of physical training so I have done
a lot of physical training and reside
quite firmly in the physical world which
is not somewhere that I did before and
that's become a part of my life however
I did go to Drama Centre London which is
a classical training with a method
approach and we did lot of physical
training there and that's where I became
first aware that the body is a tool to
be used in its entirety so the greater
control you have over your body the more
precise your physical portrayal can be
and that isn't just about
playing someone strong or someone that
can do fighting or anything like that
it's really about maintaining control
over a different physical attitude when
I first started on Game of Thrones it
wasn't a small production but it wasn't
the vast machine that it is now but in
those days where the show wasn't in
enormous global success for instance you
noted a working season 2 season 3 and it
really felt they could a group of actors
thrown together all working hard to
craft the scenes to get the most out of
the scenes talked to really work this
drama and make that come to life the key
to successful collaboration with your
other actors on set I don't know I mean
I think it's about being generous part
of my training was about the ensemble
was about being perfect and ensemble and
about it not just being about you but if
you give the emphasis to other people if
you give the power to other people in
the scene who are all doing that's when
it starts to sing and having a good
laugh always helps the writing has been
absolutely incredible and I feel really
privileged to have played that part and
to have received that kind of writing to
work with the storyline with Jamie
Lannister has been incredible and the
scenes I've left love best have been my
scenes with Nikolaj coster-waldau
because he's taught me so much about
acting I know you're gonna love me
saying that and that he has may mean how
not to do it no I'm joking he has taught
me so much and it's been amazing to have
that sort of play going on but to work
with an actor who's so committed and so
generous and so caring towards you and
wants to make sure that you are that you
are safe and also to make you not safe
and I think the bathtub scene was an
amazing scene actually getting to watch
Nikolai's work at such close quarters
and to leave myself open and really be
deeply affected by that performance also
fighting the bear also fighting the
hound
it's very difficult for me to talk about
the most challenging aspects of being on
the show because I am hugely lucky to
have done such a thing and and I truly I
truly am grateful and it has changed my
life you know that kind of overrides
everything else because you're aware of
how privileged you are to be in that
position it can be difficult it can be
tough you know you're outside a lot I
don't really mind that but um obviously
you know there's a there's a lot of
costume to wear and obviously a lot of
the fights can feel quite real shooting
those can be incredibly painful but look
at what it makes so no complaints any
kind of advice that I might give and I
certainly don't really feel like I'm the
right person to do this but one thing I
have learnt is never never never never
give up and never change the person that
you are obviously you know evolve or die
but be your authentic self and sometimes
the world does change and sometimes
attitudes do change I hope we see
greater diversity on our screens and I
hope we see more developed characters
for those other than the usual sorts of
people we're used to seeing
[Music]